on a book was day we talked a lot about
the needs to better integrate migrants
integration is important but granting
them accessed the labor market is also
crucial and there we see there's no
single rule we see gaps between member
states in some countries it takes less
than a day in others refugees have to
wait nine months even a whole year
before they're allowed to work so there
too we need more harmonization at your
level and finally we all agree that the
only solution to this crisis is more
European solidarity so either you do pay
we have at the moment 12 million people
in the European Union who have not been
able to find a job for more than 12
months to make it easier for long-term
unemployed to find their way back to the
labour market the Commission recently
launched a dedicated proposal today I
had the opportunity to present that
proposal to the ministers and i'm very
pleased by the outspoken support the
proposal received job seekers who have
been jobless for more than 12 months
should receive an individual assessment
at least twenty percent of the European
Social from this earmarked for social
inclusion this is almost 18 billion euro
for the pedo 2014-2020 and for the fed
the front of the for the most deprived
there is an envelope of almost 4 billion
euro and this fund as you know can
provide food and basic material
assistance as well as social inclusion
actions